to fight road with experience
I don't
roddick code court now and don't
stay with the
this is a subject in which there is no
respect
and it is not for those who are
like a taxi
in June cross the night
you can find me
reveco d code
s sport
s sport bar wind club the lines and I
am on my tour on the rise
in you as if they put their hand on my
shoulder who was the one who supported the most
white law of youtube they
are without a doubt for me
the america of that
picket test that is held  they focus on whether the
greek economy is
almost toxic and walter m
in one we have i think it's me now
so there are people
talking about if they want a merger
weeks ago and they tell me
with honors with white the way i say i'm
o mary people  like or not
in cuba in the national
interest rate is manipulated at 10 watts and reigns
everything I am seeing
in the congress center of sports sports
m
[Laughter]
León
r I know that you can you can learn
everything second I was 15 years there this
feast and that ruiz furniture to think that
in me  I mean so many that you can imagine
remember that these are teams that
are selected you won and to be there
you have to win 3 to stay in
the top four
first to
win win
more guys
the team of each sport
and
this Sunday
I can live with these people
I  i can live with what with this with
what is happening
mx1
mat
the nazim find out who is the one who was
efe regarding the sales and
inventory team to live from
madoff exclusivity to carmen werner sinn fein
this function is not present apple
the spray
anderson
i
yes no
in kiel
from the head in the hand
of the biblical pp of pipo got
from peak no one to you
m
no no
[Applause]